[Música]
esta fue mi inspiración para ser
ingeniero rompí el control remoto de mi
abuelo
recuerdo estar saltando en la cama y
respeté escuchó un golpe me asomo sobre
la orilla y luego algo similar a esto
bien son dos cosas si estoy en problemas
y wow qué es esto entonces por las
siguientes horas intentó cambiar los
cables diferentes configuraciones todo
para arreglarlo antes de que regrese
finalmente lo ensamble ofreció nuevos
botones y se enciende la televisión en
ese momento me encuentro con una emoción
llena de orgullo satisfacción y
curiosidad
simplemente inigualable porque nunca
antes había tenido este sentimiento en
el cual encuentro una solución para un
problema que yo no sabía resolver y
explorando este sentimiento
es cuando descubro que somos ingenieros
y que para ser ingeniero debe ser bueno
en la ciencia y matemática entonces esto
es lo que estudio
de estudio y fracaso y muchos me dicen
que está bien fracasar porque las
matemáticas y las ciencias son difíciles
a cuántos de nosotros no nos da un dolor
de cabeza viendo esta imagen
y a esa edad también jugaba béisbol y
recuerdo que cada vez que me pensaban lo
cual pasaba muy frecuentemente no me
decía está bien que te ponche es difícil
y ningún niño tenía miedo de jugar lo
puesto todos querían jugar entonces
porque no es lo mismo
bueno el béisbol es un deporte
qué es la ciencia lo fuera también
en la preparatoria soluciones de
ingeniería fuimos a una feria de
ingeniería y ahí encontramos a unos
robots como estos más cerca y les
pregunté qué compañía son y qué hacen se
cargaron y estuve confuso resultaban ser
estudiantes de preparatoria
me queda asombrado que estudiantes de mi
edad construyan máquinas de de esa
complejidad y lo que más me sorprendió
es de que me dijeron ustedes también
pueden entonces nos unimos a first y en
este programa que teníamos que armar
diseñar y programar robots de más de dos
metros y medio de alto 54 kilogramos de
peso en tan sólo seis semanas
además teníamos que conseguir
patrocinios en mentores de compañías y
desarrollar nuestra imagen logotipo
relaciones públicas mucho más casi como
una empresa y yo era un completo novato
me tomaba cinco minutos solamente para
poner un tornillo pero practiqué y con
la guía de mis maestros y mentores
pudimos armar un robot que solucionaba
un desafío que nosotros no sabemos
resolver antes y entonces en ese momento
me encuentro nuevamente con el
sentimiento que tenía como niño esa
emoción que me hizo querer ser ingeniero
y ahora lo sentía de nuevo sabía que
estaba en el lugar correcto
y el momento en el día de la competencia
o más bien el festival veía que
estudiantes estaban disfrazados y tenía
unos robots es de estupendo diseño muy
bellos y los equipos se llenaban de
energía y en la arena festejaban y
estaban llenos de alegría con sus porras
con sus saludos y muchos equipos a
través de todo el mundo se juntaban por
la misma pasión por la ciencia y la
tecnología unidos por un mismo amor
y no solamente aprendimos habilidades
técnicas y administrativas aprendimos
valor y carácter cualidades que nos
convertirían en líderes
y por el impacto que eso tuvo en mí y
por la oportunidad que yo tuve de
estudiar en san diego y todas las
oportunidades empecé a enseñar
entonces algo que yo dije que yo quería
tener claro es de que hacer la robótica
que no de miedo que sea divertido y
fácil de aprender y cuando empecé a
enseñar me enamoré fue mi nueva pasión
y aquí en tijuana una de las clases que
bueno de las sesiones cuidado para
aprender sobre la interfaz
interpretación computacional de los
programas los estudiantes tienen que
construir instrucciones que daban hacia
el robot yo y yo como robot yo pasaba
las instrucciones y las heras hacía para
que los estudiantes puedan puedan ver
cómo se corrió un robot dado que no
había tanto recurso lo que lo que los
estudiantes hacían s se escribían estas
instrucciones dar una cantidad de pasos
y giraron hacia una cierta cantidad de
grados hacia una cierta dirección de la
misma manera que sería en una en una
computadora pues con las computadoras
tienes que ser muy específico
y finalmente lo tradujeron a esto que es
como se interpretaría en un lenguaje de
programación y yo como robot ellos al
decirlo en la instrucción podía de
manera exitosa llevar a cabo sus
instrucciones y completar el curso
fue una experiencia realmente
inolvidable y es lo que me pase no para
hacer más porque ese mismo día una niña
me dijo que si ella también podía ser
campeona mundial de robótica dije calor
que si eso ya está más que para el éxito
solamente se necesitan tres elementos la
inspiración colaboración e innovación
una motivación que te que te haga
esforzarte hasta el máximo cada día y
recursos que te apoyen a cumplir todas
las metas y finalmente creatividad para
crear soluciones me gustaría verle ha
platicado todas las páginas que puede
visitar y todos los electrónicos que
puede conseguir para seguir
desarrollando su imaginación pero la
realidad era que no tenía en internet ni
los recursos necesarios lo único que le
pude decir es que se soltarán y se
dedicará a sus estudios y que para el
momento que ella llegue a la
preparatoria que tendría un equipo de
robótica donde podría desarrollar sus
talentos
entonces para cumplir esa promesa
me dediqué a crear equipos de robótica
aquí en tijuana
empecé con una exhibición de robótica
traje equipos de san diego
mexicali y caborca tuvimos unas
competencias en vivo y estos mismos
equipos estuvieron hablando con las
audiencias platicando sobre el proceso
de diseño sobre sus historias y cómo es
este programa los había impactado para
enseñar la comunidad de tijuana que es
la robótica también tenemos un taller de
robótica para niños porque queríamos
emocionar a los niños y capturarlos de
que vayan a través de esas mismas
emociones que yo tuve y al salir del
taller que ellos vean los robots
compitiendo y que digan su a su mamá y
su papá yo también quiero hacer eso
cuando sea grande
finalmente network por el momento que
generamos y toda la emoción y el apoyo
que tuvimos de la comunidad los
ingenieros compañías y todo siendo un
estuvieron apoyando
supe que iba a ser posible
entonces el siguiente paso es hacer un
campamento de robótica para capacitar a
los estudiantes en sus habilidades
técnicas y administrativas emocionarlos
para que estén preparados para la
competencia de robótica y fue un éxito
los estudiantes hicieron dos equipos que
son de más de 10 diferentes escuelas
entonces es emblemático de la unidad de
que ahora tenemos en tijuana por una
misma pasión están desde más de 10 10
diferentes escuelas o unidos por ese
mismo amor y es hacer los dos primeros
equipos de él del programa forest y nos
estarán representando en regional de la
ciudad de méxico
yo seguí seguiré creciendo la cantidad
de equipos de robótica en tijuana para
poder seguir cumpliendo sueños como lo
es la de esa niña que todos los niños
puedan mostrarle al mundo lo increíble
que son
porque uno de ellos no sabemos cuántos
tendrán la solución para el cáncer
crisis energética y todos los problemas
que nosotros nos enfrentamos
imagínense tener aquí mismo en tijuana
de poder cultivar ingenieros científicos
y líderes a través de todas las
comunidades
de que un joven por querer ser ingeniero
se mete a un equipo de robótica de la
misma manera que un joven se mete un
equipo de fútbol para poder jugar para
los cholos y nosotros como su comunidad
ser su porra
también para cambiar nuestra cultura de
cultivar la ciencia con ella y cambiar
la perspectiva mundial que hay de
tijuana cuantos han escuchado a tijuana
ser describí do como no sea de crimen
pobreza
o mano de obra barata
piensen en una ciudad que se reconoce
como innovativa que sea líder en ciencia
y tecnología
que si tijuana
fuera como esas yo creo que sí se puede
y lo mismo de manera que ese equipo me
dieron a mí que nosotros sí podemos
y lo hicimos les digo lo mismo y lo
estamos haciendo hagamos a tijuana una
cuna de innovación sabemos que nuestros
estudiantes y jóvenes son más que
capaces tienen la inspiración la
creatividad y ahora hay que darles la
oportunidad
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]